comment les premières nations calculait
les années oui bienvenue à part à
l'automne si c'est melissa maulin depuis
sept semaines pour répondre à une
question de jean françois je dois avouer
une chose c'est que dans tout
l'historique que j'ai appris dans tout
les partages que j'ai reçu le calcul des
années j'avoue que je n'en ai pas
entendu parler de la même manière qu'on
va calculer avant jésus-christ après
jésus-christ ou 1 2 3 et à 42 ans
c'est vraiment à pas pour ce qui est de
l'amérique du sud bien sûr on sait que
les aztèques les meilleurs avaient des
calendriers beaucoup plus développé
d'ailleurs de l'astronomie très
développée pour pouvoir calculer ces
années là le quelques des années le
calcul du temps se faisait vraiment en
cycle et on sait que des saisons alors
un peu par comme partout dans le monde
on avait des quatre saisons alors été
automne hiver printemps mais je sais que
chez les attikameks il y avait aussi les
pré saison comme le prix hiver et le pré
prétend c'est souvent des saisons qui
sont entre les deux et pourquoi on
aurait besoin de saison entre les deux
c'est que chaque saison représentait
aussi un cycle de chasse ou de kate
ainsi que dans le new team dans la forêt
dans le territoire donc quand on
arrivait à ce cycle là on changer
carrément d'alimentation se déplacer là
où il fallait et on suivait le cycle un
peu comme n'importe quel animal ou un
être vivant à les suivre donc il y avait
des saisons de lisbonne y avait des
saisons de pêche des saisons de chasse
et le prix hiver le pré printemps
souvent c'était les autres 2 on s'entend
que le prix versé quand la neige
commence à peine à tomber et qu'elle
n'est pas encore assez solide pour qu'on
puisse aller en raquettes et le
printemps mais c'est des fois quand ça
commence à fondre et qu'on peut plus se
déplacer dans le territoire donc c'est
mieux d'avoir accumulé beaucoup de
chasse pour pouvoir rester dans ces
périodes de flottement là mais par
exemple dans les récits dans les
histoires qu'on se raconte et il y avait
aussi une manière de marquer le temps
qui n'était peut-être pas celui
calculé en numérique mais vraiment des
moments d'histoire donc je sais qu'on
peut dire avant la farine pour indiquer
le moment où il ya eu les premiers
contacts avec les européens où à
l'époque où il y avait de la terre est
recouverte d'eau et c'est des gens de
leur reviennent partout puis on va
parler souvent de l'ère glaciaire quant
à eux la fonte des grands glaciers et la
montée des eaux
et même plus récemment si on veut parler
de cycle d'histoire et d'années qui sont
plus collés sur nous on va parler à
société à l'époque de ton arrière grand
père tel c'est quand ils sont allés à la
chasse quand on aurait ri grand père
était un enfant et là on va parler plus
de moments et d'histoire plutôt que de
dire qu'il y avait quatre ans ça s'est
passé
donc ça c'est l'histoire que moi je me
suis fait raconté que je connais sur
comment calculer les années comment les
données et je pense que c'était pas si
nécessaire que ce temps qu'on suivait
des cycles est temps qu'on répétait des
histoires qui permettait la survie des
nations mais on n'avait pas besoin de
temps de calcul et les années comme
c'était fait ailleurs alors
jean-françois j'espère avoir répondu à
des questions j'espère que vous
n'hésiterez pas à nous envoyer des
questions
justement si vous avez des manières de
calculer les années chez les autres
programmations partagez le avec nous et
partager aussi cette vidéo avec vos amis
je vous souhaite une très belle semaine